comme un air d'inauguration pour les 180
attractions de la fête des loges après
deux ans d'absence
un rendez-vous qui reste un amant câble
pour de nombreux visiteurs sa marque
l'été en fête le début de la fête des
loges et du coup l'année dernière comme
s'est pas ouvert ma passion de pavant
d'été en fait c'est eux qui nous marque
le début des vacances sans pénalité
compris un défilé festif a été organisée
pour célébrer cette réouverture des
réjouissances marque du soulagement des
organisateurs
après une édition 2009 un anonyme
envoyée par le bout du tunnel exactement
donc c'est vrai que là de coude avoir eu
assez de sortie de crise en tout cas et
pouvoir redémarrer en plus par la fête
des loges qui est une des foires les
plus familial que je connaisse en juin
deux cas c'était super beaucoup de
bonheur beaucoup de plaisir on a vécu
quand même voilà seize mois 18 mois
compliqués l'année dernière ça avait été
terrible que de prendre la décision je
crois qu'aucun maire avant n'avait eu à
prendre cette décision que d'annuler la
fête des loges pendant les prochaines
semaines jeunes les familles pourront
trouver leur bonheur au milieu des autos
tamponneuses de la pêche aux canards ou
encore des nombreux manèges à sensations
fortes
nous on vient plutôt pour les petits
lots on a on a des enfants dont un quart
en bas âge donc on fait on fait plutôt
plutôt calme et bon ça c'est agréable
aussi y'a pleins pleins de jeux sympas
une fête qui aura attendu après le 30
juin et la levée des restrictions du
nombre de visiteurs pour ouvrir mais ces
retrouvailles avec le public se
prolongeront en musique tous les soirs
sans exception jusqu'au 15 août prochain